DOING THIS.
>> Pete: I SEE THE LOOK THAT
YOUR GIVING ME AS YOU DON'T GIVE
ME AN ANSWER.
JOINING ME NOW STEVE SCALISE AND
FOUNDER OF THE COMMITTEE TO
UNLEASH PROSPERITY.
IF STEVE MOORE WHOSE NEWSLETTER
IS CALLED OF WHAT THE HOTLINE."
LET ME START WITH YOU STEVE.
THEY HAVEN'T RELEASED WHO'S
GOING TO PAY FOR IT, HOW MANY
WILL ACCESS IT, AND HOW IT'S
GOING TO BE PAID FOR.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE COST
OF THIS AND HAVE HER
$300 BILLION BUT IT SEEMS LIKE A
FLOATING NUMBER.
TO GO WELL, I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU
I WROTE A PIECE FOR
FoxNews.com ON THIS YESTERDAY
ABOUT HOW UNFAIR IT IS.
HOW IT FISCALLY IRRESPONSIBLE IT
IS.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN PEOPLE SO
ANGRY ABOUT SOMETHING.
BIDEN PROPOSE THIS BECAUSE HE
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE POPULAR WITH
SOME VOTERS, BUT I THINK HE'S
LAID AN EGG HERE.
THE BIG PROBLEM WITH THE BILL IS
THAT THEY DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
IT'S GOING TO COST.
THE ESTIMATE AROUND $300 BILLION
AND BY THE WAY, STEVE SCALISE
KNOWS JUST TWO WEEKS AGO THEY
PASSED A BILL SAYING WE ARE
GOING TO REDUCE THE DEFICIT AND
NOW THEY PASS A BILL THAT'S
GOING TO ADD ANOTHER
$300 BILLION.
ADDED UP, PETE, YOU LOOK IN THE
18 MONTHS JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN IN
OFFICE, FOUR TRILLIAN DOLLARS OF
SPENDING, DEBTS, MONEY PRINTING
AND YOU WONDER WHERE THE
INFLATION HAS COME FROM.
>> Pete: THEY HAVE THE GALL TO
TELL US THERE REDUCING INFLATION
IN THE DEFICIT AS IF THE NUMBERS
ADD UP.
REPRESENTATIVE, IS THIS THE NEW
REALITY?
EXECUTIVE WITH A STROKE OF THE
PEN THROUGH THE ADMINISTRATIVE
STATE CAN EFFECTIVELY WIELD THE
POWER OF THE PURSE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS MEANT FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH.
CAN REPUBLICANS OR THE NEW
MAJORITY DUE TO RAIN THIS IN?
>> YEAH, PETE, IT'S THE
UNIVERSE.
MANY ARE QUESTIONING WHETHER
THIS IS EVEN LEGAL TO DO.
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF WAS
SPECULATING IT MIGHT BE ILLEGAL.
ABOUT A YEAR AGO WHEN HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT DOING THIS, HE DID
IT ANYWAY.
THEY KNOW IT WILL ADD TO THE
DEFICIT AND THE DEBT.
I'M SEEING NUMBERS IT'S OVER
$500 BILLION IN DEFICIT SPENDING
IN ADDITION TO WHAT THEY DID
LAST WEEK.
$730 BILLION TAX INCREASE, PLUS
$87,000 AGENTS GOING AFTER
MIDDLE-CLASS PEOPLE.
BY THE WAY, INCREASING INFLATION
AND INFLATION IS DRIVEN BY THE
MAN TRILLIONS IN SPENDING THAT
YOU'VE SEEN.
LOOK AT WHAT THAT'S GOING TO DO.
ALL TO DO WHAT?
SHIFT INCOME ABOUT 85% OF
AMERICANS AND THEY'LL BE PAYING
FOR ABOUT 15% OF AMERICANS WHO
DO.
IS THAT A WEALTH TRANSFER AND
FOR WHAT?
THEY DIDN'T GET A GOOD
EDUCATION?
THEY SHOULD ASK FOR A REBATE
FROM THE COLLEGE, NOT FROM THE
HARDWORKING TAXPAYERS OF
AMERICA.
>> Pete: STEVE MOORE, TALK TO
ME ABOUT THE WEALTH TRANSFER
BECAUSE THERE'S A HUGE CHUNK OF
AMERICANS WHO WILL PAY FOR A
SMALLER CHUNK OF AMERICANS FOR
THEIR DEBT THAT THEY ACCRUE TO.
WHERE'S THE MONEY GOING FROM
WHOM TO WHOM?
>> GREAT POINT.
WE HAVE HALF THE WORKERS IN
AMERICA WHO DON'T HAVE A COLLEGE
DEGREE.
WHAT THIS BILL ESSENTIALLY WILL
DO IS TAKE $300 BILLION TO
PEOPLE WHO HAVE COLLEGE DEGREES
FROM PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
COLLEGE DEGREES.
HOW IN THE WORLD IS NOT FAIR?
WHEN I SAID PEOPLE WERE ANGRY
ABOUT THIS, WHAT REALLY MAKES
PEOPLE ANGRY IS THAT -- THIS IS
NOT WHAT AMERICA IS ABOUT.
IF YOU PLAY BY THE RULES AND YOU
GET MORE THEN.
IF YOU'RE NOT PAYING YOUR DEBTS,
YOUR DEADBEAT.
I'M GOING TO SAY THAT.
IF YOU'RE NOT DOING -- SIGNED
THE AND SAID YOU'RE GOING TO PAY
THE MONEY BACK, YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO.
ONE OTHER POINT I'M GOING TO
MAKE WHICH IS IMPORTANT, I
THICKETS THE DEATH OF THE
STUDENT LOAN PROGRAM IF THEY DO
THIS.
THINK ABOUT THIS, WHO IN THE
WORLD EVER IS GOING TO REPAY A
STUDENT LOAN?
THE PROGRAM STEVE SCALISE IS
DEAD IF THEY DO THIS BECAUSE THE
INCENTIVES ARE NEVER TO PAY YOUR
LOAN AND WAIT UNTIL THEY GIVE
YOU AN AMNESTY AND YOU DON'T
HAVE TO PAY THE MONEY BACK.
>> Pete: REPRESENTATIVE,
RESPOND TO THAT.
YOU'RE IN THE BUSINESS OF POLICY
AND POLITICS.
DEMOCRATS PROBABLY ASSUMED IT
WOULD BE WILDLY POPULAR WITH
YOUNG VOTERS.
BUT THE BACKLASH HAS BEEN
MASSIVE.
>> IT'S HORRIBLE POLICY AND
HORRIBLE POLITICS.
ONLY JOE BIDEN COULD DO A DOUBLE
WHAMMY.
YOU ARE SEEING THE LEFT GO AFTER
THIS JUST AS THE RIGHT IS GOING
AFTER IT.
STEVE MOORE TALKED ABOUT SOME
GREAT POINTS TOO.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WHY THERE'S
A STUDENT LOAN PROGRAM, IT'S TO
HELP PEOPLE GO TO COLLEGE,
GRADUATE, I WENT TO LSU AND PAID
EVERY DIME BACK.
WHAT ABOUT THE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE WHO PAY THEIR LOANS BACK?
WHAT DO YOU TELL THEM?
DON'T FORGET, THEY TOOK OVER AND
THEM BEING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TOOK OVER THE STUDENT
LOAN PROGRAM UNDER OBAMA TO PAY
FOR OBAMACARE.
YOU SAW MUSHROOMING IN STUDENT
LOAN DEBT BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS ENCOURAGING MORE
STUDENT LOAN DEBT BECAUSE THEY
HAD TO PAY FOR THE MASSIVE
GROWTH OF THE NEW PROGRAM CALLED
OBAMACARE.
MEANS THEY'RE BLOWING A
$500 BILLION DEBTS.
TO TAKE MONEY FROM ONE GROUP OF
PEOPLE AND GIVE IT TO ANOTHER.
THAT'S INSANITY AND NOT LEGAL
AND THERE IS CHALLENGES TO IT.
THE FACT THAT BIDEN'S WILLING TO
DO IT TELLS YOU A LOT ABOUT HOW
MISGUIDED THEY ARE ON THE
INFLATION DEFICIT AND WHAT'S
DRIVING ALL OF THESE MASSIVE
PROBLEMS.
>> Pete: GO AHEAD REAL QUICK.
>> WHY ARE WE HOLDING THE
UNIVERSITIES RESPONSIBLE FOR
SOME OF THE DEBT?
THEY HAVE $700 BILLION OF
ENDOWMENT.
$700 BILLION AND WHY DON'T THEY
USE THAT MONEY TO LOWER TUITION
FOR FAMILIES?
IF A SCHOOL HAS SOMEBODY GOING
THROUGH THE SCHOOL, THEY DON'T
PAY THAT DEBT BACK, I THINK THAT
THE SCHOOL SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT MONEY, NOT THE
TAXPAYER.
>> Pete: I LIKE THAT.
ACTUAL ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
STUDENT.
IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
IF STEVE